république à monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur le 18 octobre
dernier le conseil de défense a annoncé
que deux cent trente et une personnes
étrangères en situation irrégulière est
soupçonné de radicalisation serait
reconduite dans leur pays d'origine
au delà du cas particulier se pose la
question de l'efficacité de notre
système en matière de retour dans les
pays d'origine des personnes en civil
étrangères en situation irrégulière sur
notre territoire en 2019 plus de 122 me
l'obligation de quitter le territoire
national ont été prononcées moins de
15000 ont été exécutés en 2018
dans cet hémicycle le sénat a voté une
disposition assez simple qui
consisterait pour obtenir des laissez
passer consulaires des pays sources de
conditionner les villes obtention de
visas au fait que les pays acceptent de
recevoir leurs ressortissants étrangers
sur leur territoire dès lors qu'ils sont
en france en situation irrégulière
compte tenu des circonstances mais au
delà de celle ci même monsieur le
ministre
pourriez-vous reprendre à votre charge
cette proposition du sénat qui
malheureusement avait fait l'objet d'un
refus du gouvernement à l'époque et d'un
désaccord de l'assemblée nationale à
l'époque pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur d'harmonie vous avez la parole
ce président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur vous avez
raison les étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui sont définitivement
après des décisions de justice parce
qu'ils ont fait recours parce que nous
sommes un état de droit et qui ont eu de
quitter f une obligation de quitter le
territoire national de retourner dans
leur pays
c'est une évidence et nous devons
appliquer le droit
si je ressors de la période du coc vide
puisque assemble le problème notamment
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas pendant
plusieurs mois des espaces aériens
ouverts notamment avec les pays de ce
qui arrivait
vous et que c'est quand même un sujet
sur lequel l'administration peut être en
difficulté
il ya la question des laissez passer
consulaires la reconnaissance que ces
citoyens sont bien des citoyens des pays
qui viennent sur le territoire national
je suis prêt à étudier toutes les
dispositions qui conformément au droit
permettent le retour dans dé bonnes
positions de ces étrangers en situation
irrégulière j'aimerais cependant pas que
votre démonstration des mondes que ce
gouvernement serait laxiste et que
lorsque c'est une responsabilité le
détestiez courageux puisque dans la
moyenne des cinq entre 2007 et 2012
vous étiez à 12000 parents reconduite à
la frontière et que le gouvernement du
président de la république ont compris
et ecclésiaux vide et en est à 18 milles
vous aurez constaté 2002 différence il
devrait paquet de liens non plus entre
étrangers et personnes radicaliser ce
qu'il faudrait monsieur le président
c'est être fermes sont nos principes sur
la liberté d'expression
quand j'entends le président votre
groupe ce matin sur rtl dire je cite
monsieur retailleau qui donne des leçons
de fermeté à tout bout de champ oui à la
caricature mais avec une forme de
respect et ben non monsieur le président
retailleau la liberté d'expression elle
est totale même quand ça gêne elle
concerne toutes les religions et c'est
avec ce genre de format monsieur ciotti
vous a d'ailleurs corrigé
monsieur abad vous à corriger et oui
vous devrez retirer vos propos parce que
je crois monsieur prison retailleau que
ça avec des propos comme ceux ci on
encourage pas le président de la
république et leur nom être ferme comme
nous le sommes depuis ce matin
monsieur le monsieur le président buffet
ancienne ministre monsieur le ministre
je n'ignore pas que la période de 2020
compte tenu de la situation sanitaire
peut poser des difficultés
je ne conteste pas d'ailleurs les
chiffres que je vous donnais son site de
en revanche au delà de la situation
particulière je trouve qu'il serait
utile
naturellement une fois les voies de
droit épuisé et que la situation
irrégulière de l'étranger soit
définitive que l'on puisse travailler à
ce sujet car si naughton n'obtempère
noctum si nous n'obtenons pas pardon
excusez moi de laisser passer consulaire
dans de bonnes conditions et de la part
des pays sources
nous n'y arriverons jamais et
malheureusement le conditionnement en
tous les cas le fait de dire que nous ne
donnerons pas de visa si nous n'avons
pas cessé passer consulaires peut-être
un moyen de discussion vraiment le sénat
s'y était engagé je souhaite que nous
puissions continuer là-dessus